[Musique]
actuellement notre vue sa plateforme
c'est son dernier voyage sur la ligne 21
portes de gentils saint lazare la ratp a
décidé en effet dans le cadre de sa
modernisation de retirer du service ce
bon vieux bus sa plateforme
ils avaient plus d'un demi siècle
actuellement monsieur veulent un
président du conseil d'administration et
monsieur weil directeur de la ratp parle
de cet événement devant les journalistes
ce bon vieux bus les parisiens sont
nombreux à le regretter le symbole de
paris
paris comme on le croyait avant
j'ai malheureux parce que ces bornes de
bien mieux avant l'été on voit ce fait
que la plateforme comme moi
personnellement j'ai mise en scène tout
ce qui n'est pas désagréable du tout oui
très agréable on a une vue d'ensemble
sur le tout ces plateformes regrette
enfin que je regrette moi
personnellement et je crois il ya
beaucoup de personnes dans mon corps
[Musique]